Make it stick.
We want to make words,
vocabulary, structures in the
language stick in our brains.
That's the goal.
And I recently read a book
called Make It Stick by Peter C.
Brown, where he discusses
the effective strategies that
enable us to make things stick.
Now, many of the things he talks about
are things that I have in fact talked
about previously in my videos, and that is
rather than blocked learning, deliberately
trying to learn something, reading it
over and over again, you know, underlining
it, highlighting it, trying to sort of
force it into our brains, we are better
off If we space our learning activities,
study it now, study it two days later,
study it a week later, interleave it with
other subject matter, or as I do in my
language learning I will cover some of
the same material using different sources,
different starter books, learning the
same material from different angles.
Or, if I want to become familiar with
a period in history, I'm far better
off to read a variety of different
books on that particular period of
history, rather than trying to somehow
ace or master one particular book.
And he also refers to active retrieval.
When we read another book on a particular
subject, we are in fact connecting
the information we come across in that
book with information that we acquired
earlier, and which we may not always
be able to retrieve, but seeing similar
information in a different setting, in a
different book, in a different context,
helps us then to solidify our knowledge
of this material you know, a lot of
what is in his book kind of relates to
this Bloom's Pyramid of different ways
that we interact with knowledge where we
analyze, or we evaluate, or we compare.
In other words, we have to interact with
the information that we're acquiring.
We can't just try to
plug it into our brains.
In Peter Brown's book, he talks
about the importance of testing.
Testing is a form of forcing us
to retrieve what we have learned.
If we can retrieve what we have learned,
and if we can space that retrieval
activity, we're going to learn it better.
If we try harder...
To learn it, to understand it, to analyze
it, we're going to learn it better.
In other words, the richer our
engagement with that information,
the better we're going to learn.
So, we need to space our activities,
we need to interact with the
material in a meaningful way, we
shouldn't try to block learn things.
He also talks about the sort of
desirable level of difficulty.
It shouldn't be too easy, in his opinion.
Because, again, if we are...
Engaging with material in a way that
forces us to think about it, then that's
a richer, higher level of interaction,
which is going to make it easier.
Then to retain that material
in our long term memory.
Neurons that fire together, wire together.
Connecting this bit of information with
some other bit of information, it's
more likely to create a synapse that
we're going to be able to go back to.
Now, how does all of this
relate to language learning?
As I was listening, or because I was
listening to the audio book, it struck
me that a lot of the things that Peter
Brown talks about in Make It Stick
is exactly what we do if we have a,
basically an input- based approach
to language learning, or at least an
approach which involves engaging with the
language rather than trying to instruct
ourselves on how the language works
through some analysis of the grammar.
If I am covering essentially the same
range of vocabulary and language structure
in a variety of different language
contexts, then I am testing myself on
my ability to understand what I hear.
If I then try to speak using
whatever words and structures
have stuck in my brain, trying to,
you know, trot them out when I'm
speaking, I'm also testing myself.
In other words, the ultimate test
is my ability to speak to someone.
Even now in these, uh, tests like IELTS,
they're relying more and more on that face
to face test conversation with a tester.
He suggests that people are overly
optimistic in terms of their self
evaluation, and I'm sure this is true
if someone asks us, where are you in the
language, you'll perhaps give yourself
credit for more than you can do, but you
know yourself, when you're speaking, you
know where you can't remember things,
you know where you can't understand,
we know where we are in the language.
So that in a sense is a form of testing.
And if testing is the answer to
successful language instruction or
language learning, then we wouldn't have
the situation that we have at least in
the English language school system in
Canada, where we are regularly tested
and the vast majority of kids graduate
without being able to speak French.
I'm talking about French instruction
in the English language school system.
So testing itself is not the answer.
Rather, the answer is forcing ourselves
to come across different vocabulary
items, different structures, in
different contexts, rather than
trying to ace one particular subject.
So, in other words, we have to
read widely, we have to listen to
a wide range of content, so that
we're forcing our brains to retrieve
things according to a pattern that...
It doesn't have to be dictated by
some spaced repetition system, it's
sufficient that it is spaced and
therefore these words will show up with
some frequency in different contexts
that we are listening to and reading.
And as long as we continue to
engage with the content in this
way, we are in fact doing what
Peter Brown suggests in his book.
Peter Brown also refers to the
importance of knowing how people
who are learning should know
how the learning process works.
Therefore, they should know some of
these things about the importance of
interleaving and not block learning.
They should know that this much vaunted
learning styles is not true, that we
all essentially learn the same way.
Whatever our personal preferences
may be, I prefer to read, I prefer to
listen, the brain learns in the same way.
And so learning styles is not a concept
that teachers or learners should hang
their hat on, rather it's this importance
of retrieval practice, spacing the
retrieval, varying the activities.
Another concept that he talks
about, which I think is relevant
to language learning, he says...
We should try to do things
before they are explained to us.
So struggle with the language, for
example, before you have the grammar.
So if I'm going to start into
Finnish, I'll try to figure out
how does the Finnish language work?
Where are the verbs and the nouns and
try to struggle a little bit, trying
to solve the riddle of the language.
And then go to the grammar explanation
when you are curious and when you
have already had this experience with
the language, that's a much better
way than trying to teach you upfront
how the language works when you don't
have experience with the language.
I think this is an interesting book.
By the way, I will leave a PDF summary
of the book in the description box.
But I think the point that we should
have a better understanding of how
the brain learns is an important
one and that much of the learning
activity in schools that's practiced
in schools where there's an emphasis
on trying to ace material, block learn,
focus on learning this is misguided.
And we need to have an approach
that's based on more variety,
interleaving, spacing out our learning.
All of these things I think
are very relevant, very useful.
And, uh, so I bring this
book to your attention.
Uh, you should look it up and
look up relevant and related
material on the internet.
I think it'll help you for
your general learning and also
for your language learning.